despite its seriousness Avengers
infinity war is at times a pretty
light-hearted movie and in keeping with
Marvel Studios tradition a lot of its
best moments are totally improvised
we're getting into major spoilers for
infinity war so turn back now if you're
one of the three people on earth who
hasn't seen ER a new interview with the
film screenwriters and Yahoo
entertainment has shed light on one of
infinity Wars biggest laugh-out-loud
moments revealing it to be a clever bit
of improv from Dave Bautista who plays
drugs
according to Christopher Markus who
co-wrote the script for infinity war
with Stephen McFeely Bautista made a
significant addition to the script
punching the scene up by throwing in an
extra clip for Drax at the end of one
exchange Marcus explained the script
only said where is Gamora I'll do you
even better
who is Gamora and then one day Bautista
just goes I'll do you one better
why is Gamora it's like okay you're very
good at your job the hilarious Drax line
is just one of the examples from
infinity war of an actor elevating what
was in the script to something even more
resonant according to the movie's
director Joe Russo spider-man actor Tom
Hollands completely improvised his final
scene after Thanos successfully managed
to disintegrate half of all the life in
the universe thanks to the actors
heartbreakingly realistic performance
his disintegration hits many viewers the
hardest of them all while also inspiring
a pretty solid meme the improvisation
and infinity war is par for the course
for Marvel Studios which has reportedly
produced entire films are composed
mostly of improv Jeff Bridges revealed
years ago that much of 2008 syam man was
essentially improvised
saying they had an outline we would show
up for big scenes every day and we
wouldn't know what we were going to say
all the guys are in the studio tapping
her foot looking at the watch and we're
in my trailer trying to figure out our
lines man you know the loose approach
for the last film wasn't necessarily an
accident as Don Cheadle has said the
Iron Man 2 also lacked a locked-in
script explaining to be honest we did
improv a lot
we were very often sort of on a journey
of discovery in the scenes while other
movies in the MCU have generally had
completed scripts most of them of at
times allowed an atmosphere of
improvisation well you know when you're
standing around set for hours you think
you know dumb stuff to say and then
sometimes you say it when they're
rolling one of those moments took place
in Captain
Kosovo war jørgen Tony starts first
scene with Peter Parker according to the
movies official commentary track Holland
forgot the blocking of the scene while
they were shooting it and Downey telling
him to move the leg was his way of
saving the scene while staying in
character I'm the [ __ ] here so you move
the leg the second movie in the MCU The
Incredible Hulk also featured an entire
scene of improv William Hurt said that
his post-credit scene as general Ross
didn't have any lines written down here
you have an unusual problem
you should talk you should listen
each Avengers movie has at least one
great little improvised moments Tony
Stark offered Captain America some
blueberries and the Avengers because
Downey had a habit of hiding snacks
around sets and taking them out throwing
scenes a few hours all know every dirty
secret Shield has ever tried to hide
Gruber in age of Ultron Jeremy Renner
took a moment to ad-lib a joke about
shooting Quicksilver in the midst of all
the action no nobody that's drawn Ultron
was sitting on about yeah I'll be missed
little bastard but the most improper V
work in the MCU is likely Thor Ragnarok
according to director Taika Waititi I
would say we improvised from the agent
film it's an approach that feels risky
but with enough talent in the room it's
apparently an approach that works time
works real different around these parts
in any other world I'd be like millions
of years old if you're on shekhar thanks
for watching
check the loop icon to subscribe to our
youtube channel plus check all this cool
stuff we know you're loved too
[Music]
you